can you like grab a boob or something or
is that kind of weird
[Music]
so if you guys remember we have spoken
before about DeSean Watson oh yeah
Brown's quarterback who was likes to get
jerked off you used to get jerked off by
massage ladies but he all he's a little
aggressive with it special endings yeah
but he was like sexually assaulted they
didn't want to do it exactly Okay and
like he was like thrusting his dick up
and like like like while they're trying
to massage around him he's like [__]
putting this dick up I'm like I'm
actually that's actually what he was
doing yellow stoning
wait so they call it yeah because you're
like a geyser trying to yeah you're
trying to Yellowstone your [__] up like
you missed the spot you missed the spot
that one that's the tournament Kaiser at
least oh I see yeah yeah in a medical
field that's the term at geyser at least
wow so he went to these massage places
that are legit like Massage Envy and
then you would be trying to get jacked
off he would have he would do he would
go to places and then sometimes he would
have women come to his place but the
whole thing is like there's like 25 of
them and they're all like hey this was
[__] up like what you were doing in
there was [__] up why did he just get
actual professionals yeah because the
thrill isn't there oh making them do
something they don't want did some of
these women end up doing it uh yeah they
were they were forced they felt they
were forced to and they were under
duress during the situation so they
successfully sued him in open court they
settled out and and then now there's
there's still going to be
um there's the one who's pursuing
criminal charges but all the other
criminal charges were were dismissed why
also they so they settled well they
settled civilly and then yeah there's
criminal charges part was dismissed so
no criminal but civil yeah but there's
maybe another criminal um charge oh wow
being put into process do they say like
there's a reason why some of the
criminal charges were dropped like most
of them that's the prosecutor's office
isn't it it's like a lack of evidence
they don't have usually when people want
to go civil it's because they don't have
anything that will stick in criminal or
maybe they want more money
like in in criminal case it's just like
it's it's you against like the law and
then like or the your acute the accused
yeah did they did they break the law and
then do they get jail time and [__] like
that yeah yeah so the NFL suspended him
for like over 10 games
and he's about to start his first game
this Sunday against the Houston Texans
so this will be his first time playing
football in like two years whoa hey at
least it you know it it's a happy ending
for him hey
plus three dude well he's on the Browns
yeah he's LeBron do you think he's gonna
do pretty well I don't know because
nobody's seen him throw a ball I haven't
seen him don't do anything in here has
he been practicing he's been back at
practice for a couple weeks it's been
years two years football
but he's he's playing his old team so
his old team you know is where all this
stuff happens oh that's right this is
his first game back so a lot of people
have accused the NFL of like you kind of
Juiced this a little bit you had an 11
game suspension and you you scared they
did the math so that when you're yeah
because they set the suspension and then
you scheduled it so that when he's back
he's playing his old team that's a good
storyline man yeah and so here I am
talking about it because it's [__]
interesting it is interesting but that's
the that's part of like everyone's like
come on NFL did you guys do that [__]
because I was wondering when you said 10
games in my head I was thinking how do
they arise to like how do they arrive to
10 games yeah it was 11. it was above 10
it was 11 games are they losing views no
they're killing it they're doing
wonderful yeah I mean the Texans are
losing fans and the Browns are losing
fans actually because of the shot
because of DeSean they picked him up
right there's some life life for brown
fans who are like [__] this team I'm out
damn over that because they're getting
jacked off well because because it was
non-consensual yeah all over the
rapiness of it happiness so they're like
I don't want to support a team with the
race just because you got jacked off
didn't he kicked out of the team he
didn't because he's playing against his
old team right yeah so he's he's on the
Browns now and they're paying him a [__]
ton of money to be there by the way he
has like over 100 million dollars
guaranteed because at the time of uh all
these allegations when he stopped
playing was he considered like like top
five quarterbacks definitely like a
supreme Tower really I didn't know that
yeah he was he was above Dak back then
Dak Prescott back then I don't
understand if he's that good with his
hands how come he didn't Jack himself
off that's a really interesting point we
should look into that yeah if he could
[__] do this like a quarterback is
really good at doing this he just
spiraled the [__] out of his [__] yeah
he should [__] me we should throw a
football around with all of us yeah we
should have Joe teach us all how to
throw a football he's just like yeah
you gotta hit it by the end like this
and then you gotta [__] spin it like
that spiral yeah [__] spin so all
week you know when you're in when you're
gonna play an NFL game the media gets a
couple Chances with you for like you
know to interview pre-game all this
stuff so every time they're trying to
talk about what happened and
interestingly enough the lawyer
representing these women civilly has is
bringing 10 of them to the game
why he got a sweet and he's just
bringing them to the game
kind of interesting what's the
relationship with him or something what
what's the thought that we should look
into that I think it's kind of I know
it's wild right we need to go back to
the scene of the Cross do you think it's
one of those game plays where it's like
the other team's like hey make sure you
bring those girls here to [__] with his
head kinda to see his downfall or
something like that kind of yeah because
he might suck at football now because we
don't know he hasn't played any
psychologically missed but if I was one
of those chicks I would be like I don't
want to go [__] game yeah that's so
weird
even if it was for like a payback thing
you know what I mean like if even if I
wanted to [__] with his head I'd be like
dude I think they've been paid out about
it so what the that's weird because if
settlements are reached usually there's
like stipulations where like okay now
that I've paid you you can't talk about
this you can't do this I don't want to
see you why the [__] are they like so
that wasn't in maybe it was his request
he's like hey now I pay you guys out uh
one condition you have to come back to
my comeback game you got to support me
yeah right you know what I mean you got
to support me so it's like it's all good
for the Texas
if you're not gonna Jack me up at least
come to my game because usually
settlements are brokered by lawyers and
usually the lawyer is gonna put as much
[__] in as possible if you're having to
pay them it's like okay we'll pay you
but a through z like you can't just
[__] show up you can't do this you
can't like just to you know this is
usually a lot he did end up saying like
just to be clear you guys aren't going
to jack me off anymore
because after I pay you does that mean I
get a lifetime supply of jacking off
he's like what am I pay for exactly he
doesn't even know
so do I get jacked off first and
he's like the Browns gave me 230 million
dollars guaranteed so I could buy a lot
of handies with that but I don't think I
think it's like Ryan was saying I think
he likes the um it's they don't know and
then he can kind of like tempt them with
his first he's like going to Massage
Envy and he's all like do you do
anything extra and then they're like
yeah we do oils hot stone and he goes
Hard Rock
she's like like uh don't they just throw
you out when you start saying [__] like
that if you're in there and you're like
what about that yeah they should water
toward you on the spot
pour a bucket of water over your head
the ones you soak your feet in well the
Hard Rock I've heard of I've heard of a
dude who uh and I and I I don't think
this person's lying but he said he he
got a handy at it Massage Envy wow which
is really like rare I guess because it's
like because they're corporate yeah
they're corporate up to the description
of the massage therapist exactly in most
cases they just look like nurses in a
you know it's not very sexy and I'm
getting horny
it looks like an institution imagine you
walk in
um it's not very sexy in here
it smells good but it doesn't look good
start critiquing a little corporate
what are you gonna do about this
literally seeing a lot of skin do you
have to wear scrubs no I don't know have
you been jerked off in a massage parlor
yes
yes can I ask do you was it in the
United States
no do you look pretty sexy can you like
grab a boob or something or is that kind
of weird I don't know I guess these are
really important questions yeah no the
logistics of it are fascinating to me
yeah you can't really reach oh you can't
I don't know so how do you how do you
miss you like no no it's like you know
how like when they're massaging you
they're like is this okay and then
you're like oh yeah yeah and for you
when you they flip you around and like
you're getting they it's like okay and
then they're like yes or no right
remember that time I got we bought a
massage for your birthday oh yeah in
Whittier right yeah
but I was [__] dying because you
could kind of hear like at what point
everyone is right because they have a
pattern and a routine and then so like I
think
um my massage
was kind of coming to an end and then
his massage therapist heard it so they
did this half-assed job when they were
like
okay yeah yeah I got a full leg massage
and Karen got like
yeah okay finished they started after
too so but they didn't I don't know it's
weird lazy got ripped off huh it's okay
I've I've had plenty I had a massage one
time and the lady picked up a phone call
in the middle this [__] was talking on
the phone did she put the phone on your
back on speaker she put on my phone she
put it on top of my head no she had this
is a [__] up part that would have been
better than what she did she just had
one hand oh no I was like yeah she was
picking Mandarin and I was like oh this
is terrible oh this is like this is an
awful massage but anyway listen to this
business conversation yeah I did it was
it was a good time though what were they
talking about I don't know I don't
really understand Mandarin if they're
speaking Spanish I could pick it up a
lot better so the women who are going to
the game they they just want to make it
uh known that they're still here and
that they matter that's the idea yeah
it's their choice 10 10 of them are are
going to the Sunday game
wouldn't it be crazy if they were like
dressed like crazy bronze fans with like
the [__] helmet and sunglasses like
all the [__] shoulder pads and [__]
with the spikes
with the number one yeah and they just
got like towels and lotion and stuff in
their heads oh no they're Browns fans
that's crazy but they love the the
defense they don't like the offense they
don't like the offensive line or
anything like that yeah they're just all
defense they shouldn't they watch all
the defensive plays they shouldn't love
the defense it's pretty good it still
boggled my mind that like so many so
many of these incidents happen with
athletes when there's like so much money
on the line and reputation they don't
have a [__] person to come in and
there's like coaching all of them on how
to [__] like conduct yeah do dirty
the right way yeah but it's like you're
DeSean Watson bro you can't Crush puss
wherever you go go to a club are you
kidding me these [__] are throwing
stuff you should have 230 million
dollars guaranteed yeah dude yeah but
then it's not fun which I I could see
that maybe he likes the the
sorry the grapiness but also you're the
editor you go ahead yeah whatever you
want and leave that one in though it's
kind of like people that like the chase
more than the when you actually get it
it's like oh when it comes too easily
it's like I don't want it you know yeah
maybe that's what it is that's how you
feel about grape huh that's how you feel
about it no
that's how that's what I'm saying that's
what he might be he's a quarterback
that's who he is so that's probably the
same thing where if he was about to
throw it and everyone just went go ahead
he'd probably be like
[__] oh [__] yeah yeah play defense what
are you guys doing man he never passes
somebody that's open he's like what the
[__] going on here man what if he goes
and buys his his hand job it's like it's
there where's the fun in that for him
right is that what it is you know it's
kind of sad too maybe it's just porn
addiction or something maybe what's kind
of sad too is that there's a quarterback
named Jacoby Brissette Colts used to
have him he's [__] dope he's now the
Browns quarterback he's been like
stepping in for Deshawn because Deshawn
was just was suspended he just like he's
won a string of games for them he's done
good for them he just beat he just won
the other night like and nobody thought
they were gonna win and as he's getting
off the field
um he's like emotional because he knows
because he gave DeSean so much
guaranteed he's not going to be seeing
the field again
that's whack bro he got [__] over yeah
dude because he beat the um
creepy there was a good [__] team it
was um
huh no we're not the [__] they told me
you guys were filming
it was the bucks he beat the bucks he's
still hit me in the Bucks and he used to
be on the Patriots too oh [__] what
that's crazy
you know what you might as well finish
it Bart you should be turning the
cameras off
[Music]
back